hi this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today we're learning more about McDonald
vs Chicago a 2010 Supreme Court case
challenging a handgun ban in the city of
Chicago the question at issue was
whether the Fourteenth Amendments due
process
or immunities clause means that the
Second Amendment right to keep and bear
arms for the purposes of self-defense is
applicable to the states or put more
plainly the Second Amendment says the
federal government can't infringe on
citizens rights to keep and bear arms
but can state governments to learn more
about McDonald vs Chicago
I talked to two experts Alan Gura is a
lawyer who argued McDonald vs Chicago
before the Supreme Court
Elizabeth Y drew is a Supreme Court
litigator and the president of the
constitutional accountability Center
so MS Wydra could you set the stage for
us who were the challengers in this case
and why did they decide to sue the lead
plaintiff is or was Otis McDonald then
76 year-old african-american retired
maintenance engineer who lived in a part
of Chicago and wanted to have a gun for
self defense a handgun two pricks
himself and his family in his home he
lived in a neighborhood that had grown
increasingly trouble old with gang and
drug-related violence and he felt that
he wanted to have a handgun to protect
his wife and his family after his home
had been broken into several times but
because the city of Chicago had strict
rules barring handguns he and three
other Chicago residents brought their
case into court asking the court to find
that the individual right to keep and
bear arms including a handgun for
self-defense in the home that had been
recognized just a few years earlier by
the Supreme Court with respect to the
federal government also applies to the
states and cities like Chicago in 2008
the Supreme Court had held that the
Second Amendment to the Constitution
guarantees Americans the right to have
guns for the purpose of self-defense but
that case took place in Washington DC
and
Washington DC is sort of a unique
creature in our law it's a federal city
it's not located in any particular state
and so everything that the city of
Washington does is essentially done by
the federal government or a unit of the
federal government to which the Bill of
Rights applies directly but historically
the Bill of Rights was never thought to
apply directly to limit what cities and
states could do so what were some of the
competing interpretations that were at
issue in this case well there were a
number of interpretations that were at
issue the 14th amendment has several
parts to it in the first section of the
Fourteenth Amendment it states that no
state shall make or enforce any law
which shall abridge the privileges or
immunities of citizens of the United
States and then it also says among other
things that states can't deprive people
of due process when it comes time to
regulating their life liberty or
property states may not deprive anyone
of life liberty or property without due
process of law when it comes to your
basic civil rights the question had
always been whether or not the states
are bound not to violate your civil
rights because they are told not to
abridge the privileges or immunities of
American citizens or are your rights not
to be violated because the states can't
deprive you of due process of law so
when the drafters of the 14th amendment
were coming together to think about what
rights would be protected in the 14th
amendment they looked at a lot of the
abuses by state governments of key
rights that had been previously
protected against federal government
action in the bill of rights and when
they were debating what rights would be
included in these protections against
state action they talked repeatedly
about the importance of the right to
keep and bear arms but the way they
talked about it was very different from
the way that we think about the 18th
century revolutionary founders talking
about the right to keep and bear arms in
that case it was very much about the
militia and preventing the tyranny of
government action in the 14th Amendment
context the right to keep and bear arms
was very much an individual right they
were concerned about freed persons being
subject to white militia violence and
being able to protect themselves with a
gun in their house and so that was
really one of the ways in which they
wanted to protect the individual right
to keep and bear arms different from the
way that I think the founders thought
about it when they were drafting the
Second Amendment yeah this is a really
interesting point because you can kind
of see how these things evolve over time
and particularly in the 1860s after the
Civil War there are many local or state
statutes known as the Black Codes that
specifically prevented newly free
African Americans from owning firearms
or any kind of weapon exactly and that
was a concern because one it was a right
that they considered to be a right of
citizenship but two and more practically
and more immediately of concern for the
people who were being targeted by this
racial violence it was something that
was a question of life or death for them
and the the debates on this by the
drafters of the 14th amendment were very
clear and very colorful senator Samuel
Pomeroy described how indispensable the
right to keep and bear arms was and how
important it was that the fourteenth
amount of protection that right he said
during the debates every man should have
the right to bear arms for the defense
of himself and family and his homestead
and if the cabin door of the freedmen is
broken open and the intruder enters for
purposes as vile as were known to
slavery then should a well loaded musket
be in the hand of the occupant to send
the polluted wretch to another world
where his wretchedness will forever
remain complete so going back to the
Macdonald case how did the court rule in
this case MacDonald we made two
arguments for why we should win the
first argument we made was the
historically more obvious one although
it's one that the courts had not often
entertained and that's the argument that
says that when the
to amendment provided that the people
cannot be deprived of the privileges or
immunities of American citizenship that
means it couldn't be deprived of their
basic fundamental rights right there in
text the 14th amendment it tells you
that that you can't be deprived of the
rights of American citizenship secondly
we made the argument that and this is
the argument that the courts have been
more open to over the years we made the
argument that where the state is
prohibited from depriving Otis McDonald
and other Chicago residents of due
process of law
you can't deprive someone of due process
that means not just that the state can't
do things arbitrarily not just that Otis
McDonald is entitled to some procedural
protections in the way that he's
regulated but also that there are some
results some things that simply cannot
be done and taking away someone's
firearms in violation of the Second
Amendment rights is not something that
the state can do there's no procedure
that the state could could create to
achieve that they would still be
considered to be giving somebody due
process of law so the court said what we
have done when we've looked at
individual rights under the Fourteenth
Amendment and whether or not original
Bill of Rights rights that were
initially understood to limit the
federal government applied to the States
is look at whether or not they are part
of what we generally talk about as
fundamental to our scheme of ordered
liberty or stated another way the
question is whether the right is firmly
rooted in this nation's history and
tradition and when they looked at that
question with respect to the right to
keep and bear arms they looked at a lot
of the reconstruction history and said
this was clearly something that the
drafters of the 14th amendment
considered to be very fundamental to
ordered liberty and thought that indeed
the freed men the african-american
people of the south who have been
subject to the slave power and people
across the country who had been subject
to discrimination from the states should
be able to look to the Constitution to
protect the right to keep and bear arms
as their individual right just
as the court had held in the Heller case
they could be able to look to the
Constitution for protection of that
right against the federal government so
in the McDonald case how did the
majority of the Court Rule the justices
broke down in multiple different ways
there were four justices led by Justice
Alito who refused to look any further at
the privileges or immunities clause they
thought it was old it was water the
bridge they were not interested in
looking to see whether or not the courts
erasing of that provision was legitimate
even it's widely agreed to be
illegitimate today but the court didn't
want to go there and instead those four
justices led by Justice League know that
the Due Process Clause incorporates the
Second Amendment right to keep their
arms as against the states because it is
a fundamental right it's deeply rooted
in our nation's history and traditions
it's something that's very basic to our
understanding of our civil and political
institutions before justices thought the
right to keep their arms is fundamental
there was actually a debate among the
members of the majority who all believed
that there was a right to have a handgun
in the house for self-defense that was
protected against state and local
government regulations but just as
Thomas would have found that right
through another means he would have
looked at the privileges or immunities
Clause of the Fourteenth Amendment
instead of the now accepted method of
looking at the due process Liberty
Clause of the Fourteenth Amendment which
is how these other provisions of the
Bill of Rights have been incorporated
against the states there were many
arguments including I should say a brief
that I filed on behalf of scholars from
across the ideological spectrum who said
that in fact the privileges or
immunities Clause of the Fourteenth
Amendment is the part of that
constitutional amendment that was
intended to protect this particular
substantive right as well as the other
substantive rights of the Bill of Rights
against state infringement just as
Thomas's
concurrent's did not get any other votes
rather from the people who were against
the right to keep and bear arms or those
who didn't but it is an important
contribution to thinking about how we
understand rights and where they are
protected in the Constitution's justice
Thomas's opinion in McDonald is
groundbreaking it represents the first
time since 1868 that the original
meaning of the Fourteenth Amendments
privileges or immunities caused the
basic protection that we have for civil
rights in this country against state and
local governments was decisive in a case
at the Supreme Court it's been that long
since a true original understanding of
the Fourteenth Amendment
proven to be decisive there were of
course justices who thought that there
is not an individual right to have a
handgun in the home for self-defense
these were the same justices not
surprisingly who thought that there
wasn't a Second Amendment right to be
protected against federal government
action to keep a handgun in the home for
self-defense they would have thought
that this was much more a right in the
Second Amendment context that had to do
with militia service military service
and therefore it did not extend to an
individual right to have a gun in the
home for self-defense
mcDonald's really a fourteenth of every
case I mean guns happen to be you know
the thing that was in it but but I
always seemed primarily as a this is a
Fourteenth Amendment case it's not only
a case that tells you anything about the
scope of the Second Amendment in fact it
doesn't say anything about the scope
with a second one very little there are
many issues left to be resolved in the
Second Amendment context the Heller case
itself which first articulated that
there was a right for individuals to
keep in bear arms in their homes for
self defense made clear that it wasn't
saying that there could be no gun
regulation that case even though was
written by Justice Scalia and certainly
in the McDonald case justice Alito's
majority opinion reiterated this said
that while there were certain laws that
would be struck down as unconstitutional
because they pro
but in the possession of handguns in the
home they recognized at the same time
that the right to keep and bear arms is
not a right to keep and carry any weapon
whatsoever in any manner whatsoever and
for whatever purpose so given that the
court itself and even very conservative
justices recognized that there could be
and perhaps should be common-sense
limitations on both the types of guns
that are allowed the manner in which
they are allowed and where they can be
taken and in what manner then a lot of
the gun regulations that are being
passed are still very much part of the
constitutional debate we've seen frankly
most of the laws thus far be upheld as
constitutional laws that for example
target assault weapons high-capacity
magazines and certain licensing and
registration requirements so I think we
will see more cases to define the
contours of the individual right to keep
and bear arms as these gun regulations
get passed and as the courts get to pass
upon their constitutionality so we've
learned that the Supreme Court ruled
that the Fourteenth Amendments Due
Process Clause that no state can deprive
a citizen of life liberty or property
without due process of law did
incorporate the Second Amendment into
the states under the reasoning that the
right to keep and bear arms for
self-defense is fundamental to the
nation's scheme of ordered Liberty
according to Alan Gura even though this
case was about guns it was really a
Fourteenth Amendment case concerning
whether states can restrict citizens
Liberty Elizabeth wide rahowa ver
cautions that the decision in McDonald
didn't preclude any restriction on gun
ownership and she suspects that new
cases will continue to define the
individual rights to keep and bear arms
to learn more about this case visit the
National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution and Khan
Academy's resources on US government and
politics